the art of making a big entrance is
something chit come on Wiz it knows a
lot about it's given him a platform to
tackle what he says is the greatest
Scourge to afflict Thailand the
corruption is part of the Tha people
life you can see the corruption
everywhere so when I talk about the the
the corruption I know
it it feel like a
natural in my gut
at today's media Circus the focus is the
current prime minister and allegations
of impropriety in land deals an
accusation that's been vigorously denied
the chain of evidence is long and
complicated with much room for dispute
but the cameras are here for the man not
the facts Mr chewit is an unlikely and
some would say flawed hero he started
his career as a massage parlor owner the
perfect place he says to learn about
corruption I am Hugh hner I am the
Playboy I am a pimp I am a politician I
am the
media I am what I am a short period as a
politician ended when he was jailed for
illegal eviction then released early
under a royal pardon since then he's
rarely been out of the public eye
claiming the role of national
whistleblower critics of Mr tuart say
that his anti-corruption campaigns are
all about promoting his own business
agenda and that he only takes on the
police police and politicians because of
his business
interests others say the problem is the
erosion of real democracy in
Thailand we got to
democratize for me this time is um very
hard for Tha Society we have a uh
constitution written by uh by the co
Mr CHT is delivering his folder of
evidence to the police but this will be
his last fight he says a cancer
diagnosis is forcing him to retire from
the public eye the spotlight will turn
off the Kamala will turn off and
everybody go
out that is the end and happy to do that
enough is enough Tony Chang alaz Bangkok